hello everybody my name is tatus petra
and i run the amateur coder channel
where our goal is to explain things so
simply that even amateurs can understand
it
and that's my goal for today's video as
well to be able to explain
how to build a complete production ready
app from scratch
as simply as i can so the topics we're
going to cover today are planning which
in my opinion
doesn't get covered enough and i think
it's one of the most important parts of
building any software
some other steps you take before you
start building an app
building an actual app then there's
three types of testing that we're going
to cover
and finally maintainability and
hopefully by the end of this video
you'll be able to be confident about the
apps that you're releasing to all the
app stores
i'd like to thank free codecamp for
giving me this opportunity
and i think all my links will be in the
description if you want to check them
out
and let's get into the video okay so
today the app we're building is going to
be a very simple to-do app
now the code for this app isn't going to
be too complex we're going to focus on
the process and make sure we go through
all the steps necessary to be confident
about launching our application
and to start with that is planning i
think planning is the most overlooked
topic when it comes to
creating any type of software especially
creating an app
we're going to focus on two main parts
of planning today
one of them is requirements
and then design so what are requirements
it basically breaks down the big
requirement of build a to-do app into
smaller sections that are more
achievable
and that you can test at the end so
we're gonna have requirements like the
following we're gonna have
create account
be able to login be able to sign up
only display not finished to do's
keep the list synced up with firebase
and lastly if no to-do's say that
there's no unfinished
dues be able to add a to-do and check
off to do's
now for each of the topics we're going
to get in today there's whole
methodologies about how to do them
and just like for example requirements
there's ways to actually structure the
sentences
in a way using words like shao and must
but today we're going to keep it simple
if you're interested in any of these
make sure to do more research
we just can't cover it within like a
couple hours
so we got eight requirements for this
app now let's get into the design a
little bit
so with design i like to use adobe xd
and there's other options like that you
can use but for this one we're just
gonna do some very basic
drops so we'll have the
login screen and then we'll have a login
screen so here we're going to have a
field for
the email the password and then
a login button and then a register
button
nothing too complicated then once inside
will have
an app bar with a
sign out and then add
to do and then down here
just a list of to-do's you want to kind
of get gain a vision for how the app's
going to work and make sure
all the parts are thought out for
example if we didn't think about the
sign up button at the top and we wanted
to put something else at the top
it gets a little clearer up there you
just want to think about it now the
design doesn't only include how the app
looks
there's also the architectural design of
it
so for this app it's pretty simple we're
going to have we're going to have the
main
which will check for authentication
and this is not a widget this is just a
check then if the authentication data
hasn't been received
we're going to show a loading screen if
there's an error we're going to show an
error screen
if there's no user logged in we're going
to take them to the login screen
and then finally if they are logged in
we're going to take them to the home
screen
now inside these two
inside the login screen will have a
username widget a password widget
and then two buttons then on the home
screen we're going to have a
sign out button and add to do widget
and then a list of the to-do's
so this is pretty much the way to treat
there's software like jaw.i o that you
can use but
this works for us so that's all the
planning we're going to do for
this specific app but a more complex app
should have
days or even weeks of planning in my
opinion
the things you need to think about are
object oriented principles and stuff
like that you can look up the
principles called solid and grasp
those will help you separate the widgets
out
and keep your architecture clean all
right and next is to create some sort of
version control and some way to be
organized
i think almost everybody uses github
nowadays so
make sure you create a github project
and
create some tickets and issues in there
that you want to work on things like
that
and then finally we can start on the
code so
so i'll go do that right now i'll set up
a new flutter project and
a new firebase project and connect to it
okay so we got our firebase project with
the email and password sign-in method
enabled
we're able to run our app once to make
sure it works so then i
imported these three packages so we
could use everything we need with
firebase
and then also lint along with analysis
options.yaml
so we can have a static analysis tool
that
tells us where we can improve our app
performance so here you see problems
with const
we can add that before
and now our app will technically be a
little bit faster now we got a little
bit more preparation before we're ready
to start
i'm going to set up our folder structure
folder structure is very important to
make sure you have everything organized
and you can access it real quickly so
this is the one i use but every project
should be a little bit different
depending on what it needs
so i have a screens folder a models
folder
a services folder and
a global widgets folder or we'll just
call it widgets
so models are like bits of data that go
together for us we're going to use
a to-do model which will basically
consist of data that
is included within every to-do then we
have screens we're going to have the
login screen on the home screen
services we're going to have two
services authentication
and the database service and then we
have global widgets
we're only going to have one in there
called the to do card which basically
will make all our to-do's look the same
so now we ready to start not yet there's
still some more decisions to make
now the final decisions you should think
about before starting your app
whether you want to do tdd which is test
driven development
this is actually a really great way to
write apps but
i personally don't like it too much
because i find a little bit boring i
like to
write a little bit of code and then
write the test for it right after
then there's the state management
decisions for
us we're not going to use any state
management solutions other than set
state because it's such a simple app
but state management is a huge topic and
will definitely clean up your app
architecture a lot so
definitely take a look at the top three
are provider get x and block
so you could take a look at look at each
of those and see which one you prefer
and now finally i think we're ready to
get started so one thing to keep in mind
when you're building an app keep things
simple and keep them iterative
so that means do one small part at a
time make sure you check all of it
everything works and test it all those
things
so the first part we're going to start
with is getting our connection to
firebase working
so this part's actually pretty simple
there's a new firebase.flutter.dev
website
that kind of helps you out and
this is the initialization code that
we're just going to copy
and paste right in here
so the code in here runs the app
you first initialize the app and return
a future builder
which depends on that initialization
so this future builder pretty much takes
in the future and builds depending on
what state that future is in
so if the future has an error we're
going to return
a scaffold with
a center child
text error
very simple and then you see the blue
that's our linter popping up saying we
need to fix that
then if our connection is done that
means it was successful
and you can go to your app we're not
going to touch that yet
and then the last case is it's still
loading that if it doesn't have an error
and it's not done yet
then you know the only option left is
loading
we're going to return the same thing
except we're gonna say loading
now the most important part if the
connection is done and secure
we're ready to move on to our app also
one thing to keep in mind we're gonna go
through this code a little bit fast
because
there's a good amount of code in there
but we want to mainly focus on the
testing
aspect of it but i still want to go
through the code a little bit so you
kind of get like a
thought process of how you think through
building an
app so we have our firebase
connected now there's another
precondition we need to check whether
the user is authenticated or not
so we're going to do it inside a root
widget
which is going to be stateful
so you can put this in another file but
for simplicity i just put it in here
and this is going to send us to our root
so root is going to decide where the
next page is
so now inside our widget we're going to
create our firebase
auth instance
firebase auth i'll call it
auth and then firebase auth.instance
and then while we're here might as well
create a
firestore one
firebase firestore
so then we get into the actual return
type i like to use a stream builder for
the authentication because
anytime anything changes with your
authentication state it'll be updated
because it's being streamed
so the way we do this is we need to give
it a stream
and our stream is actually not defined
here so we're gonna have an
auth stream so remember i told you
there's gonna be two services that we
have
one for connecting to the database which
is firestore and then one for the
authentication
so let's do the authentication part
we'll have a file called auth.dart and
here
we'll have a class called auth
we're going to pass in a firebase
auth instance
and does create a constructor for it and
we're going to have three functions in
here one is going to be a stream
of type user which is a type return from
firebase
now we're gonna get that from auth off
state changes
so any time the state changes will get
returned a user and all the data for it
so just like that
then we'll have three other functions
one's going to be called create account
we're going to need to pass an email
and a password
anything that's related to the future i
always make sure to wrap and i try and
catch
because if anything goes wrong then you
it gets caught here
here we're not going to actually do
anything we're just going to re-throw it
back but
if you want to create any actions based
off of a problem occurring like maybe a
snack bar
you want to make sure you return
whatever you want to return
then inside this try catch we're going
to have
create user with email and password
very simple passing the email password
and we're actually going to do
email.trim
just in case they put a space after it
then if that's successful we're going to
return
success and now the reason i made a
return a string is because we're going
to also do
an on firebase auth exception
now we're going to catch that as well
and return a dot message for that
so basically if there's an exception
from firebase auth
it catches it in this variable e and
it'll return a message for you
basically why it failed then we can
return that from this function give a
little snack bar or something telling
them
that it failed and why so we have two
more functions
one for signing in and one for signing
out
i don't think we need to go through that
they're going to be pretty much the same
all right so that's it that's our three
functions that's all we're going to need
for the authentication
notice how clean this code is all we're
going to have to do is call this create
account function
and everything is going to be handled
for us so now in the main we finally
have
our auth class
and remember we need to pass in a
parameter called
auth and then the string that we're
looking for
is for the user stream
this errors we'll see is because it's
not a named
parameter and you just do that by adding
in brackets
to make sure it's named i like to make
sure everything is named for myself
so we have our stream defined now
the builder notice everything's filled
out for us we have our context and
a snapshot of our current user if our
snapshot
connection state is equal to connection
dot
dot active which means our
authentication stream is
active basically otherwise you want to
return another loading state
just like that now if it is active we
have a couple more conditions to check
so snapshot.data
and we can look for the uid if the uid
is no
then we know there's nobody logged in
otherwise
uid is not null we'll know there's
someone logged in
so these two screens are going to be
real simple so i'll make those real
quick and be right back
all right so both of those are done
they're both very simple
the login screen has two text form
fields and two razor buttons that don't
do anything just now
and the home screen just has an app bar
so here if the snow
return login with
an authentication of auth
and a firestore of firestore
now we're doing a lot of passing
authentication and firestore everywhere
this is why i think you should use some
sort of state management because you
only need to pass those around
everywhere but
it's not too bad for us
then over here we're going to return the
home screen
and we're going to need an auth of auth
again
and firestore of firestore
now within to do widget we have the two
functions
for signing in and create an account all
we do here is call those functions we
created
so this will return a success or the
error message if you remember
we're gonna need to do auth and sign in
the user
with email
from the email controller
and password from the
password controller
dot text then we can check if the
return value is equal to success
then we can clear those controllers
otherwise let's display a
snack bar with the return value because
remember we'll return the error
okay
copy paste that and add it here
obviously it'd be nice to have another
function like this but i think since
it's such a small piece of code it's
okay and we only do it twice
so not too bad
long screen should be done and i think
we can run the app at this point and see
if it works or not
and of course things can't work on the
first try like that
but it's actually pretty simple we never
wrapped it in a material app or anything
so make sure this future builder is
wrapped
in a material app
and then this should be the home and we
might as well add some theme
and make it dark theme because you know
we're programmers that's
that's kind of what we stick to and
there we go
let's see if it's working so we create a
username
let's just type anything signed in
password is invalid
and the user does not have a password or
the user does not have a password okay
so let's try tatis
gmail.com password one two three
four five six sign in
there's no user record correspondence
identifier user may have been deleted
okay then let's create an account first
we created an account and
there we go we're back in the home
screen
now last part before we start testing is
let's actually create do something
when we try to sign out so here we need
an auth again
we have our authentication pass to this
and we can just do sign out easy
and now hopefully we click it and we'll
go back to the main screen
now we're able to type in our email
again
and this time we're able we're not able
to create an account just email our
address is already in use but we're able
to sign in
there we go that's our full complete
login process
now after this stage is where the
testing begins so the nice thing about
test driven development or tdd
is that at this point you're pretty much
done you know your app is fully tested
and that everything works but for us
we don't have that yet so we're gonna
add some unit tests so what unit tests
are they basically test
the unit per se so a unit
is just a function pretty much and the
only things that really make sense to
test in this application
are these functions that we have create
account sign in
and sign out you also want to make be
careful about not writing useless tests
you don't need to write a test for every
little simple thing you do
in fact there's probably an argument
that these don't really need to be
tested since
firebase already tests this for you
and you're not really you're not really
testing much but
just for demonstration we're going to go
through it so the reason i wanted to go
over is because these tests
could be a little bit more complicated
given that they need
mocks in them so we're going to need to
add some more dependencies in here
we're going to add mokito and then we're
also going to add flutter
driver and test but those are for
the integration test for this one we
only need moquito
and flutter test so each of your tests
needs a main
and then inside your again you can have
a setup
and a tear down
so what these are the setup runs before
every single test and the tear down runs
after every single test
then checking back to this class what
was the one thing i said we're going to
need this firebase auth in order to do
anything we need this authentication
but for us we're going to be mocking it
so it's not calling the actual
database so like i said the thing we
need to mock
is the authentication class
so we will create a mock auth class
the way you mark it is you need to
extend that class with
with a mock you'll see we have a library
imported
the mokito library and then it
implements
our firebase auth class
so basically this says we're mocking our
firebase auth class
and this is the class that will contain
all the mocks
so once we have our class defined we can
create an instance of it and now we will
be able to use this for all our tests
so our first test we're going to call
emit occurs so we're going to test that
this
off state changes actually emits and we
get a user from it
we do that by overwriting the function
up here
so auth state changes you just type it
out
i'll send you this whole thing and what
we'll need to use
is a stream
dot from iterable now inside here we're
going to iterate over
the type of objects that you use so you
saw this should return our user
so we're going to do is create a mock
user as well so we'll have mock user
extends
mock implements
user and then here we can return a
mock user so before we get to the actual
test case i want to change this name to
mock firebase auth
just to make sure we're all clear that
this is the firebase authentication
our our class is actually called mock as
well so we're not mocking this class
we're mocking the
firebase auth that we're passing in so
now we can
create our instance of our auth class as
well
and remember we have to pass in an
authentication
and that authentication is going to be
mock firebase auth
so there now we have our auth class that
we can use for all our tests
so here we want to call expect later
which is for anything with futures
and we're expecting the auth user class
to return
a stream which we can check by emits
in order and inside here we'll have the
mock
user so there we go
now if we run it well you'll actually
see a problem
there so we're expecting
an emit of the type mock user instead we
got an instance of
generated stream of just user
so what happened here well in flutter if
you have two instances of an object
let's say you do this simple check
if you do mock user is equal to
mock user even though they are exactly
the same this will always return false
this is because a separate instance of a
mock user is not equal to a different
instance
there are packages like equatable and
other ones i'm pretty sure that
actually check the properties within i
tell you whether they're equal or not
but since we're not using that we have
another option
you can create a variable for mock user
and then use the same instance within
this iterable
and this emit check
so now if we save and run
everything passes
great so we got the mission there now go
back to this function
and we need to check this first part
whether create an account works
so you can copy paste that and check
create account
so here the difference is we want to
mock an actual call to database so we
want to mock this
create user with email and password
we're not trying to override it like we
did here
we're trying to catch it and then return
something of our own instead of the
database
so you will need to do when and then
inside
basically do when the mock mock firebase
auth
dot create user with email and password
gets called
with the fields we'll say tatusa
gmail.com
and password one two three four five six
so when that happens then answer
and we put in whatever value we wanted
to answer with
so actually in this case we don't really
care where it answers it will
just return success no matter what the
answer is
unless it throws an exception that's the
only way it doesn't return a success
and it will throw an exception if this
wasn't
successful basically
so we mark it we don't really care what
the return is
and then we can do and expect where we
await our
auth class
create account and we
want if we don't pass anything that
means
these aren't going to get called to the
specific fields that we mentioned here
so we want to make sure we pass the
email of todas
gmail.com and
password of one two three four five six
now since it gets called with those
exact fields it will return
with a success
okay let's try to run it
perfect it works
now we could check the same thing except
for this firebase auth exception make
sure the
exceptions actually work create account
exception so when this function gets
called
instead of turning null let's actually
throw
a firebase auth exception and you can
put your own message like
you screwed up now we can actually copy
this message
and that should be our return for that
function now we can run all three
actually to check
all of them pass perfect
now i'm going to copy paste these
and we'll do for
sign in i will do sign in with email
password pass those in
sign in that should run
sign in exception
you do sign in with email password
sign in function gets called perfect now
we should be able to run those
that one runs
this one runs and then we could do the
same thing with
sign out these don't need any calls
let's check how this function works so
success if it's no
and same thing with exception
very easy sign out and there we go now
we can run all of these tests
and we have one two three four five six
seven eight
tests that all pass let's say firebase
gets updated or something
and the signed out function works
differently our tests will not pass
anymore
and now we have full coverage for all of
our authentication functions
and let's say firebase updates they no
longer throw a firebase auth exception
they throw something else
then one of our tests is going to fail
when we run it
because we only catch a firebase auth
exception
we don't catch the other ones so our
code is more safe and you'll be able to
catch problems with anything you
interface with
and you'll know that it's not your app
that's actually broken into something
else
so that's it now there's another type of
testing called widget testing
widget basically tests your ui
the thing is we don't really have
anything that's
driven with the ui here we just have a
sign in screen that
is based off of the firebase database
it's not really
ui changes right so we'll come back to
that and the integration tests after we
do the to-do lists
so for this next part we're just going
to go through the database interfaces
because the rest is just making ui to
work with it and
i don't think that brings too much value
for you guys
so we're going to need a to do model
and here we're going to have a to do
model class
with a to do id
the content of the to do
and then whether it's finished or not
then we're also going to give it a
name constructor from document
snapshot
going to want to pass in a document
snapshot for it
then in here just simply set the to-do
id
equals document snapshot dot
id content equals
document snapshot.data
content as string
and then same thing for the done
except as boolean okay
so now our database class we're gonna
need to pass in firebase firestore
and the constructor for that and then
we're going to have
a stream of the list of to do's that we
have
so stream of list of to do
model
i'm going to call that function stream
to do's
and all we need is the uid of the user
so the way our database is going to work
we're going to have a collection called
to do's
then have a document with the uid
and then within that uid we're gonna
have the to do is for that specific
user and then we're gonna have the to-do
id
content and done
so that's what our databases are going
to look like very simple
and easy to use so for the stream
you want to again try catch as always
and we will try to return firestore
that collection remember to do's
collection
that document of
the uid we passed in and then that
collection
of to do's
and we only want to get the ones
where the done field is equal
to false
and then we want the snapshots of that
so that returns a stream but we want a
stream of list of to-do models
so we gotta map it to such a list
these snapshots will return a query for
us
and then i like to space it out even
more
we will have a list of to do models that
we want to return
at the end we've got to make sure to
return that and then here we're going to
have a for loop
for
each document
in query dot
docs so all the documents that that
query returns we're going to iterate
through every single one
and then append to the list we
have with a to-do model
from document snapshot and a pass in
that document
okay that was a mouthful but
it's not as bad as it looks so we return
a query
and then we go through every document of
that query add it to this list
then return that list through a stream
that's pretty much it so then we have
two more functions
i'm just i'm just going to go over them
with you there's not too much to them
this one's to add a to do if you
remember we need the id
and what the content of it is so we'll
find the collection name to do's go to
that specific uid
go to the collection call to do's again
and add a document
with the content and the done field is
false
then we want to update that to do so
we'll have the uid
and then the to-do id so we're able to
get to the specific
to do item
and we just update the done to true so
i'll go ahead and make the ui
and use this and then i'll be right back
okay so here we have the home screen
we have list app we can call it
amateur coder
to do instead nice
so i have our sign on at the top we have
a text saying add to do here
a text form field an icon button which
calls our add to do function that we
created
and then a list of your to-do's inside
of a stream builder
which takes in the stream to-do's that
we created
and then similar to when we log in we
have a snapshot
if it's active and our data is empty
means
we don't have any to use want to return
you don't have any unfinished to do's
and if we do we have a list built list
view builder
which returns a list of to do cards
and to do cards are just a card with
an expanded text and a check box next to
it
and if we click on the check inside the
check box it will update
our to do to be checked
so let's see if it works for the fun of
it go
eat a hot dog we can add that
go get a hot dog perfect if we refresh
here
showed up uid and then to do and here we
go
and the cool thing is
if we update here you'll see it update
right there right away
and same thing we got a check box we
click it it's gone from here
that's turned to true and you're good to
go
if you want to implement another screen
saying
to do is that we're finished you can
take this code and do it
it's in the description
but now to test it so remember the fact
that i told you about
there's no need to have useless tests
all these things in firestore are
already tested so writing tests for
these doesn't give us much value
actually so we're going to skip the unit
test for this
if you want to do it it's very similar
to the way we did the authentication
tests
so you can try that on your own so the
thing with flutter is there's two more
different types of tests there's widget
tests and then there's integration tests
now what widget tests are is they test
how your ui
reacts if you click or touch something
so basically it's
ui tests the thing about our app that we
created
is there's nothing driven by the actual
ui everything is streamed
so when you click this button you're not
doing anything within the page
you're actually just sending it to
firestore and then unrelatedly
the stream builder updates once the
firestore
data comes in so there's nothing really
to widget test here
but i still wanted to show you how
widget tests work
and i have a to do app that doesn't use
a database so let's look into that
okay so this is the to-do app it looks
pretty similar right
except there's one big difference we
have a controller
and this list isn't being streamed from
firebase or anything it's just
a static list that we're holding in the
app
as well the database isn't actually a
database it's just a
future that returns from database
and true so if we look at the app you
can add things like
hello add it and then load to do from
database
you load it in from database and it's
checked but if we reload it
it's all gone anyways this means it's
ui driven now this button when we click
it actually does something within our
app
before the button click sends it to the
server and then comes back right
so here we have some widget tests we're
just going to go over them because
i think widget tests have a lot of
material online i think
integration and unit tests are the ones
that are a little bit less covered and
if you want more information about
widget test
unit test and integration test i have
videos
more dedicated to that topic on my
channel so make sure to check those out
but we're going to read through this
simple widget test that i have
so this test is called add a to do and
remove it
and you'll see we have this tester.pump
widget
so it's pump widget basically means in
its ram or in its memory it brings that
widget
up in the background like we don't need
to we don't need to be running this and
this test will work
some background it launches this widget
we wrap it in a material app because
you need a material app to launch
anything or at least use the scaffold
then we launch our home screen then we
have these
add field and add button they have a
value key on them
so if you go back to our home screen you
can add things called keys to
the buttons and form fields and that
makes it a lot easier to find them
with our widget test
you can also do
find by type
by type what type of widget it is by
tool tip
things like that there's more than more
than just that way to find stuff
and also we'll have find dot text get
groceries
so this basically looks through
everything in the widget tree and see if
there's a text
called get groceries
so now for the actual widget tests
we use the widget tester the same one we
use to pump the home widget
so we bring the widget basically onto
the screen
we enter the text get groceries into the
ad field
we tap the add button and then
we call this pump function which
rebuilds
just basically like set state does
and then we can expect
to find a get groceries
so message finder
basically tries to find a text called
get groceries
and we tell it that it should only find
one of them
so we can run this now and it passes
let's say we do finds nothing
it doesn't find any widgets
so basically we add a text field and
we're expecting it not to show up
we have a problem right there said it
actually did find that
so that's all we're going to cover for
widget tests there's a lot more
documentation on the flutter docs you
can watch come to my channel check out
the videos if you need some more help
but it's not too complex the most
complex one in my opinion
is the integration testing okay so we
covered unit tests which go over the
function
then we cover the widget test which goes
over a whole widget
and now the last one is integration test
and that goes over the app as a whole
but to do that you need to run the app
there's no way you can really test the
app as a whole
without running it if you remember we
added this flutter driver
so this flutter driver is the one that
pretty much does the
driving of the integration tests so
we're going to do is add another folder
called
test underscore
driver and here we're going to need two
files we're going to need a app
dot dart and we're going to need a
app underscore test.dart
inside the app dot dot we're just going
to copy the flutter documentation
and this basically runs the main of our
app
call the main function of the app or
call run app with any widget you are
interested in testing
so then for the actual app test we're
going to go to the documentation again
and copy the the code that they have
okay now let's read through this so this
imports the flutter driver api
all good we have all the finders that we
have just like we
checked in the widget test except
there's a by
value key so it's a little different
syntax but similar idea
then in the setup we want to connect to
the flutter driver and then
close it whenever we tear down and then
they have two
tests here we can remove these tests
we don't need them our first test will
be
create account
we're actually going to have three tests
total so you can just
put them in here already we'll have a
create account
we'll have a login and then we'll have
add a to do so notice we're doing
creating the account that means it has
to call the
firebase server right and that's
perfectly fine with integration tests
you can do that
it actually builds the whole app with
the firebase connected to it and you can
actually run the tests but i would
recommend doing this
not on the production server and have a
different firebase project
that you connect when you do testing so
what i'm going to do right now is i'm
going to go through the whole app
and add a bunch of these value keys
because we need to use them
so on the login we have the
value key called username
and we can make a constant and i'll be
back when i do this with
every widget that we're going to need to
use
okay so these are all the objects that
we're going to be using in our
integration test we have the username
password
sign in create account sign out button
add field add button
so now in the create account first
i want to check if there is a sign
out button present because this builds
the app and launches it if our
authentication is already there we're
going to be
already logged in this test is going to
fail because
we're already logged in with an account
so there's this function i made called
is present
basically it looks for the value key and
it waits for
a certain timeout that we pass in which
one second
if it doesn't find it within one second
it'll throw an exception
we return false if it does find it
within one second
it will continue and we will say that it
is present
so pretty simple
so we check if our sign out
button is present then we want to await
driver which is what drives the actual
test
and we want to tap on the sign out
button
so we'll check if it's there if it is
sign out
once that's done we're going to await
driver like i said this thing basically
does everything for you within the app
you want to first tap on the username
field
just like you would use the app you have
to tap there first in order to type
right
now i can copy it and enter
text and here we'll enter
let's say tatus1 gmail.com
taught us that gmail is already taken so
we get an error in this case
obviously i don't know if this create an
account test
is worth making since this is testing
whether firebase works or not
but we're just doing it for
demonstration purposes
hopefully you will learn something
so then let's tap the password field
enter the password
very secure one two three four five six
and then we finally
tap the create
account button
so that should have done the test for us
now what do we do next we just wait
for find
the text called your
to-dos if you remember on the home
screen there was
added to do and then there was your
to-do so we find the text we know this
worked
and now this integration test is done
and we can run it
so the way you run the test is you do
flutter
drive target and you put the
test driver app.dart that we made over
here
as the target so this will enable the
flutter driver extension then run your
app
and then run your tests
so if we click it let's see what happens
so i was in the wrong directory but then
i got to the right one and here's us
running the
flutter driver and then there's multiple
devices found
i have an iphone connected an ipad and
then this is the iphone 11 pro so we
want two
so there we go it's done and now it's
launching
it'll start off logged in i think
it's logged in logged out you saw that
got pressed
and everything worked all your tests
passed
and now if we check firebase taught us
one
gmail.com so there we go
that's how integration tests work
now let's quickly add these last two
we'll pretty much copy this one
if it's present sign out if it's not
enter the password and then instead of
create account button
let's do sign in button then add a to-do
want to check if it is signed in already
just because we don't want to
do be doing to-do's while we're in the
login screen
if it is tap the add field
which is this part enter the text
make a video for free code camp
then tap the add button and then let's
wait for
the text
make a video for free code camp to show
up also you can add your own timeout in
here if you want
let's stay say three seconds
make that constant again and now let's
remove this tata swan at gmail
so get that problem again and
we can run our integration test again
it's running you see logged in logged
out log back in and created us to do for
make a video for free code camp
nice that was pretty cool i wish you
could slow it down a bit
so there we go we have created a pretty
robust to-do list app
uh it has unit tests it has integration
tests doesn't have any widget test but
if there was anything ui driven would
have definitely done it there's also one
more type of testing called functional
testing
this is pretty manual so i didn't really
go over that
but you also want to make sure you play
around with your app by yourself make
sure the ui looks good like for example
all our tests would have still passed if
this to do screen right here
if this to do was off the screen it
would have still worked because it's
technically within the
widget so you want to make sure
everything looks good as well
and the animations behave as as you want
things like that
now the last point i wanted to go over
was maintainability
things you should keep in mind as you
work on this project because i'm sure
you made a to-do app there's a lot of
updates i want to push to this right to
make it even better
so one thing one great thing for
maintainability is to set up a ci cd
pipeline cicd stands for continuous
integration
and continuous deployment or delivery i
don't know i've seen both
basically this gives you the ability to
set up a pipeline where you push your
changes to the master
and then it runs a test for you it
builds the code it checks everything and
deploys the app store
all automatically i think it's very
useful and
makes it more reliable that like your
release will happen the same exact way
every time
i have a video about this on my channel
if you want to check it out
it's for code magic with flutter it
seems to be the go to cicd
platform for flutter another big thing
is to make sure you keep up with your
tests
as you go because i know even if you do
it at the beginning
it's hard to always keep up with them
but they will definitely save you time
in the future
when you have updates make sure you
break it down in github keep it
organized
make sure you break it down into simple
tasks because you want to make sure you
incrementally change and everything
works
incrementally this way you can track
where things go wrong
and make sure they don't go wrong i
guess in the first place and then as you
keep building up to it
if you keep your architecture principles
in check
and keep your testing up to date you
will be a lot more confident about your
app and you'll be
able to release the app store with less
bugs and people will enjoy the user
experience a lot more
and as you go forward i'd make sure you
go through the whole process we went
through today for every change
make sure you check the requirements go
through the design the widget tree
planning all that stuff
uh it might be a little bit tedious but
for smaller changes it won't
shouldn't be that bad and i'll
definitely make your
process a lot more smoother so that's
been it for me
once again i'd like to thank free code
camp for giving me this opportunity
if you want any more in-depth details
about any of the topics we covered make
sure to come to my channel i have videos
on
almost all these i think this code will
be in the description
and i'll also add the code for the
widget testing as well
and that's it for me thank you for
watching